learn crime lover of Nazi weapons mr.
Chris waters anti like boys here to show
us off the video game mario kart 8 which
comes out friday how is this game out
yeah we reviewed it like a month ago I
know because Nintendo had so much
confidence that people are going to love
it but they're like we're gonna give you
two weeks to digest all the words in the
reviews yeah and you're gonna like this
I loved it it's amazing ok let's look I
feel like we should stop straight into
it sure is hot right and we're gonna
play this type of game that is best
enjoyed by playing and by playing in
general yeah vs race is that just gonna
be you versus now we're gonna have
computers but then we can jump around we
don't they do a cup we can we're gonna
do as much as we want I'm gonna do lack
of two cuz lakitu what is like it too
he's the dude from super mario brothers
who throws the spy knees sure i'm gonna
be this Cooper kid with a beer ludwig
von coop is king ludwig from / new van
Styne you have any questions for Tom and
Chris about mario kart by all means put
them in the chat put a minute twitch
chat gamespot comments if gamespot is up
cuz i know we're down at the moment and
if you can't get through to that feel
free to send them to ask gamespot on
twitter yes yes i have chosen we're
going to do 150 see because you are
super good at being 156 oh yeah how many
races your thing we're gonna get in it's
probably solid probably too many
probably five yeah probably more like
that and all right Tom man give me this
give me a mario kart 8 hello similar and
how is it different than new oh what the
heck kind of caution is this you want me
to talk about the game I want to talk
about video games so I really the thing
that I love about this game is that like
so recent Mario Kart games have been
kind of a mess where you be hit by their
shells and like if you were first it was
a punishment talking up like mario kart
7 on 3ds marker seven was much better
than that but like the wii version
double dash yeah for like it just kind
of been a theme especially with the
console mario karts des was also like
that this game is totally like if you
get into first and you're good you can
stay in first which is crazy to think
about because
no mario kart game in many many many
used to beat you up and try and get to
the front like as late as possible yeah
yeah that wasn't it would be would it
would not behoove you to be in first yes
which is crazy that you would want to do
that and of course I'm showing how good
that is but I'm in seventh place right
now nailing it tall I know I know and I
chose my favorite course in the game too
this is the one retro course that is
from Super Mario Kart which is still my
favorite of the series I have any
throwbacks are in this then Rainbow Road
counter for what do you would you ask
have any throwback levels Oh their 16th
relic level so there's no oh there's no
battle arenas or final specific arenas
there's none of those cool battle the
other 16 16 new tracks 16 retro like but
they made edits to them right now like
this this thing where I just jump in the
water there that's not in the original
like you can't jump in the water on the
super-mo geez features even with mode 7
you can do that you've got the boomerang
there as well right together that's a
new thing I don't know what else to say
about it other than it's a boomerang I
got a piranha that's also a new thing
I'm not try to chomp somebody you can
successfully chomp people with the prize
I keep doing a speed boost as well oh
yeah yes and it makes me all year round
turns because it's like grabbing the
ground and boosting you I'm gonna ask a
bunch of questions cuz ya'll on Twitch
be thrown a real quick and Danny Hibiki
asks is dry bones and unlockable
character no no that is a cry of dismay
from tom I like dry bone dry bone hee
hee diddy are the two characters who
were in previous games that I've most
lamented were not in this is wet bones
on unlock of my car yes ok he is
non-canonical listening bones yes moist
bones there we go wait that don't that
yellow Sanchez asked will mario kart 8
be coming to 3ds no but it's better that
I can't wait for terrible I know your
knife you didn't play the game as much
as me I didn't play the game for 30
hours and 33 Gold Cup every cup on the
cutting circuit I don't want to brag but
you can brag for me can I talk to you
about the Battle of this stuff because
this was quite a and I was quite
irritated when I saw this yeah so the
battle mode in this game generally the
battle levels are kind of
like self-enclosed arenas arenas yes
what what's happened this time because
they're not arenas it just like it like
circle they're just circuits so I rato
angry it's like a loop of the one of
these tracks has been converted into a
battle arena they just loop it and
everyone starts at different places on
the course and like something facing
different directions there's no like hey
you're going the wrong way lakitu that's
the key it's going to come down they've
made some changes to it but it's like
well just buries wealth right out yeah
you're the spot some spots there's bots
in the bottle check it out at some point
yeah should we play these five races so
you guys can see what they are but it's
not like I don't know it hasn't been
great for like a decade but I don't
think that's the way to fix it I thought
that I could get on a different way
eminem's lane Eminem street is what a
concept Tom motion is pining for a
different battle mode in 200 I don't
know I mean I still light battle mode in
all the games but I guess it hasn't like
the the first two mario karts i love the
battle mode i guess it hasn't had the
same excitement to the right on the same
old thing every time but i guess just
making the courses worse doesn't make it
better for me clearly Eminem stranger
asks do i need to play it all seven of
the previous games to understand this
one yes okay definitely a bob jones 1980
is online play any good I mean it's like
you'd expect you play online against
people how many people 12 oh really
which is a lot of people be playing
mario kart with do you tend to get 12
people when you were doing it I guess
it's not out yet just howling no I did
not get to all people oh yeah I'm all
right mark hearts always good online
like it's the chats kind of garbage and
you can't chant during races black
pepper and it's just split screen online
yes but only two players can't park a
player shame and technology dude
technology crimson gesture asks pro
controller or gamepad I only use the
gamepad but it's not you for a great but
whatever it's good there's a big button
on it for horn there's a big button on
he's a [ __ ] and I touch it you can you
can touch it all you want their you're
going to touch you where is it it's the
giant Wow and where
it's right there where you yep yeah
maybe we're coming out of the actual TV
or is it only coming out of the gamepad
think it's coming at a TV can't hear it
how often does the super form show up
ask sing shun 102 well as you as you to
notice we played almost six crack or
whatevers laps left left and uh Tom
neither of us have got tom don't be in
first right so that's that's the one for
getting rid of the blue shower right yes
or any item all right it just
neutralizes any incoming item situation
it's pretty rare there's also blue
shells aren't that prevalence I mean
we've actually gotten one in each race
which is a lot usually it's not even one
per race hmm the lightning is a lot of
lightning come on you small child at
David Fox 1983 asked i heard the frame
rate goes down from 60 certain amount of
players i noticed this when we did for
oh yeah so goes down about 30 so the way
it only works with four players is the
game this is really technical do you
want me to talk to do it so digital
found you broke this stuff down the game
always runs at 60 frames a second when
it's four player the top screen in
bottom screen ultra nate there refresh
rate okay so it's like top refreshes and
bottom and like that so they both run 30
frames a second right but the HUD moves
60 frames aside okay there's actually
another weird thing so every 60 this is
really technical okay you guys ready for
this yeah yeah every 60 North frame is
duplicated rice which some people swear
they see a hitch but I didn't hear
anyone say that before digital foundry
talked about it Ron he's gonna go
there's good why don't live in San
didn't hear anyone I usually owes you
can see you can pick out one of every
sixty four frames with your eyes and see
a hitch I guess I I don't see it even
like when I'm told like right the 138
mark I don't let him see that but if you
have really sensitive eyes you wanna I
don't know I feel bad if you can notice
that but so what's your overall visual
impression this game is ridiculously
good-looking we're digging like ER so
you civ ago what do you love so much
about 80 it's colorful yeah I got some
nice environmental video or Latino I
don't know it just doesn't look pretty
it's a hey look
all good and it's just like a game I
want to exist in because it look I just
looked you want to live in this yeah you
having like oh god all yeah yes yes yeah
this is his new life now this is my new
life I played so many hours of those
game little big kids are his friends at
dude in bit dude I'm baked on tricks
asks can i play with my friends online
without having them next to me
presumably this person is usually pretty
smoked up in his room when he wants to
play smart yeah I get paranoid there you
are next to me is a random you cannot
use or can you lay with people that it's
like you can't because I can't invite
system intended woods you can't like
find someone on your wii u friends I
don't know Richard again it's just like
Nintendo so back we friend zone yeah I
just do not Bob Jones like so and so if
you had a friend if you have to pray
with like in hypotheticals with us like
how would you actually connect with them
just like you I think it both go to the
room I don't know it's kind of creepy
because a lot of those a lot of the room
are you referring to their living room
yeah it's so much better like the other
car smell since be online all rights
Pokey is speaking of that local a book I
actually used to go to lobby of my
apartment 4d s and I would just play it
all alone in the chair I'm in first yay
your shield I called this that sonny
bono bono memorial run and Cara doesn't
like when I do that because thats dark
humor that's a really dark humor and Tom
does the framerate drop with three
players each other asking I think it's
more than two let's test today next race
we quit out of this when you've done
this I'm not super sensitive to that
kind of stuff or it always ran smooth
than me whatever at Bob John 1980 asks
what's the local I'm sorry what's a
maximum out of local players you can
offer but or should be five what an
intact as you could put it on the tablet
you could put one of the players in
really fun in time but whatever I know
some games have had five right Raymond
Ray mint at five yeah but wasn't one of
those five Murphy
arab bukas ass is shy guy the best
character in the game ah no Cooper
trivet good question good question come
on get some yeah yeah lots cordage out
on the slopes I like this track because
it doesn't loop at all I know there's
two tracks like that I think there's two
directed only I that's one of the
reasons actions that I actually called
out this in my review I like the warrio
warrio trash I'm gonna get you with a
boomerang in the face oh it didn't come
back Oh had you know all right let's get
me in on this is there another alright
yeah there's another controller under
here what else can you you want the
nunchuck heard you want the pro
controller oh I'm giving me the pro is
that wireless sure sure it I mean not
technically why got tireless there so if
there's a wire between the things right
so I can change this the gamepad to a
map to a map ok which you'd never look
down at I got it yeah well I don't know
why would ever do that well then if you
play split screen it shows the
split-screen grid on the tablet it shows
the four player split it's like what
this is your tech Nintendo this is your
thing put use the tablet in a cool way
that's not just honking I'm hitting it
so Oh griping my number table thinking
my number 2 i'm number what I don't know
how I'm in just did the line on it what
I'm in what you're not in how did you oh
you were because you were Ludwig that
was confusing me are you as someone yeah
no I'm gonna use some way okay I'm gonna
be shy guy cuz that person in the chat
I'm gonna be wario eukanuba you can pick
your your your setup as well your your
frame and your wheels and stuff yeah
have you not into that I just think it's
just detract from the game i think it's
just nonsense this isn't yet I sense I
it's like I don't need to tinker I just
want to play a game that's fun I don't
know you comparing my aircard to fort
set because I'm put a daffodil on my
friggin yeah okay I mean I don't know
it's like dan it's called the livery not
to name names but Matt max McGee used to
spend forever like trying to figure out
I don't I don't you know I don't want to
wait for your still take shadow I am a
pan general we are now doing I guess
I'll make some kind of make them we do
battle I'm doing battle we are doing
battle bad can you do without computer
people just three people it's soo
okay I got you want to do and you though
no yes just get you can okay it is it's
you need it so we can do any tracking
will do this one you've got a yoshi
island track yo Kelly oh this is one
where you drive off the edge all the
time if you're some disk if you're not
good at Rainbow Road isn't their future
rainbow road in this yeah all rainbow
road's future Oh some are magical summer
from the distant past in a galaxy far
far away which one's go I don't know
I've somehow managed to choose a motor
so nice it's good thing we're on battle
mode cuz i just started in Reverse wait
so who's down the bottom right that's
just a computer yeah a nun races it
shows Susan first but no it's not the
computer Joe Susan first right yeah but
I don't know who is it show it means I'm
good wait stuff it's just a glamour shot
of tom okay so this is an example of the
frame rate ah sure BAM that's a thing
eat it whatever you just were that was
near me I god I'm not sure on twitch if
you can really if you could have told
you know could tell other like earlier
that it was better but it's definitely
you can tell yeah I can tell I could go
yeah like it's you know it's not really
hindering my experience of playing mario
kart but still it's like you say that
like it's like Mario you say with this
like you spit it out no it's a higher
than our Mario Kart it's I don't know
nice to try a sucker broke down ciao no
i'm using the tactile stay in the
goddamn hell away from all you Joker's
how are you knowing where we Joker's is
I'm going around the circle basically Oh
hurry up there with me oh no I ran into
a thing a banana Oh in your face who's
for Tom I mean I got that wasn't one of
you it was calm that's so I probably
stuck it to the calm oh are you learning
again oh dang it Tom Mario's what I do
what do you mean what you know what you
did ok I can't really see anything
specific keep getting one green show
every time lucky really brag about it I
want to go sit on that bridge like a big
fat troll
let me shoot you off this bridge yes
technically I would be under the bridge
yeah I was a real troll just like
Anthony Kiedis he's the trouble I
thought that movie with that song is
about drugs it was actually a troll the
whole time every one of his songs is
about heroin and or halal Slavic every
one of their songs lazy it is true you
say halal Slavic he's the guy he's their
first guitarist who died for when I'm
like 85 hey Tom I guess it'll just
happen I know you got uh but I get to
drive sorry what were you guys saying
when you said halal Slavic I thought you
meant like you know me ste you can eat
as a Muslim that's from Poland that's
not what he meant no what would it was
gradually peppers first guitarists ok
you died over heroin / sins name yeah oh
you know we didn't I have a heroin
overdose go Oh shy guy who's I'm in
seconds sit segue and you know you're in
second sorry I've got two balloons
that's nice I'm live my number says he
fine what does that even mean I'm what
is the number mean am I just player 5
how many people know that I can I just
say I'm allying against Nomar art over
the reverse right in the Mario oh dang
it what are you saying Danny can I just
say yeah I did the battle modes thing I
really wish this was an arena how do you
feel about it Chris it just makes
everyone feel very spread out you can't
like it feels like it's hard to line up
vectors yeah how do we what what what
yeah so what is it because I had that
many hits Tom we've got six I'm not
answering I want to play anymore what
balamani sucks Racing's bono we're back
to everything you're supposed to answer
questions that are asked of you that's
your job on this show needs any more
questions you guys play I'm gonna see
the same work whether you jump again yes
okay I'm gonna be one do you can tell
the cheese a girl should I be the bow
danny is Erica single character name and
the twitch chat has anyone made mention
of any character at all pink gold PETA
is shy guy you're so too late it's pink
gold peach or such a trouble and that's
again you use that as steering wheel as
a question yes you can't if you're weird
would you want to use those see it yeah
I'll do it
yeah good okay I need so much a
reputation operation what does that mean
and I guess if you can't succeed with
the steering wheel it won't be all
succeed it's a steering wheel for
chrissake where you see me driving real
life uh I'm good for pedestrian I do not
succeed with a steering wheel in real
life cesano theft asks what the upgrade
system for the car parts are like do you
unlock those bits or are they all just
there on them yeah you upgrade them by
getting coins okay so coins not only
give you speed but they also they go
towards getting a daffodil or whatever
so when you can they don't upgrade it
just alternate opens new ones yeah every
500 or something you collect is a 550
it's a big difference but every X number
just automatically gives us a 50 I'm
gonna say 500 a new track but I do put
random oh ok and you collect their every
single star in this game and it didn't
give you anything mmm well you don't
collect stars it's that's all rights
like a rating to like if you get all
first in every Cup you get three star
rating and it uh you get you get say
forgetting she is doing it he's doing
this lyrics looking to do it were like
he's shaking it you know you can
separate it must be trying to aim that
thing with a lie will I'm gonna do it
success I don't trust a man I did try
not failed yeah come on Tom believe in
your still do it yes in your heart
totally just hits Awards of boomerangs
wanna vga he's not the winner this is
all you have to hold it like above your
head like a real driving car right there
like a five-year-old driving a real car
I'll be although right in the drink okay
something all the nasty drink that's
like a brown goopy drink hustle avocado
milkshake Hassan on twitch asks why are
there so many baby characters why are
there so many baby characters listen
baby fivb character babies are one of
the top five types of humans there are
so it really makes sense for them to be
statistically Reverend what's the worst
baby character they put in this game
baby daisy okay cuz daisy is already
like an artificial character and that
she doesn't even exist outside their
artificial care
she doesn't exist outside the sports
universe is I don't think she does does
she I don't know ok mission so I wish
everyone spin-off and then happened
jay-z's Roc and Raj having arcade game
in Japan no I don't thinks it's like had
it don't have it like a and then there's
like the palate floss fizzy metal mario
and there's pink gold peeps which are
nonsense and gold p don't you say that
about pink gold beach what is the pay
for the longest time they'll actually
thought it was two colors like pink gold
and gold now pink going it's a little
it's a medal yeah pink coat just like
just like metal is a type of metal metal
mario yeah i didn't whatever I thought
it was like whatever they couldn't even
make it titanium mario i know in my
review for seven when when metal mario
was first in mario kart I said like
that's not even a real character
apparently I still stand by this can all
right for that infection and he's not a
real care Briony Daisy was in Mario Land
the movie Daisy movie nazy macomb Mario
Land maryland and the movie oh and it
was in the bob hoskins get up canonical
huh that's if that's not canon I don't
know what is I think okay well she was
in mario land that's something something
i guess more than you are in that's one
more than I Daisy's IMDb is way she's
like the portable princess whoa okay is
that her though I don't know the
portable princess come on I that's a
niche and then the other one is beach
are they both princesses I want some
Daisy fanfic careful what you wish for
Tom turning is so hard when it's turning
like I'm gonna do the whole race and I'm
switching back pickled peaches number
want a normal nice look thanks daddy
gotcha let I appreciate your support
congratulate a lot to me thank you have
you in my corner this uh you're not
honking the horn enough he's doing it
you decide it no more look at the screen
that's the whole screen more faster a
weird horn
slower mario kart a's wanted to guess
what squirty to get a nice it's all
right there are a few more games with
building at a perfect score Oh John if
anybody